more than 30 people were killed this
morning and a pair of bombings in
Afghanistan one of the attacks was in
the capital Kabul the other north of the
city the bombings came after the death
of another US servicemen Charlie d'Agata
is in Kabul Charlie what are you
learning about these attacks
well good morning it's a tragic reality
that these kind of explosions and
bombings and attacks happen every day in
Afghanistan why these matter is where
they happened let's start with that
first one in part one that's north of
here a suicide bomber on a motorcycle
blew himself up that happened in the
middle of a crowd near an election rally
for president Ashraf Ghani we contacted
his spokesman who told us President his
entourage were unhurt and as a matter of
fact even continued that rally anyway
the second one that happened here in
Kabul maybe around 200 yards from the US
Embassy
it's a congested intersection near US
and NATO compounds in fact it's it's a
place that we've passed through several
times ourselves
this comes after US officials confirm
the death of a u.s. Green Beret who is
killed in action yesterday that now
makes 17 US service members who have
been killed here this year that's more
since the higher death toll since 2014
now the Taliban has claimed
responsibility for these recent bombings
and they're making good on threats that
they made after President Trump canceled
peace talks here that they would go on
the attack and since we've been here
it's exactly what we've seen an increase
in fighting from both sides Gail thank
you very much Charlie d'Agata reporting
from Afghanistan